un día vergonzoso para pakistán así se
refirió el primer ministro y rancan a lo
que sucedió el viernes cuando una turba
golpeó y prendió en fuego a un gerente
ceylan de una fábrica ubicada en la
ciudad de sialkot al nordeste de sri
lanka la policía general para la región
de punjab ha dicho que los culpables
serán castigados pronto
hicimos redadas en más de 200 lugares en
menos de 24 horas para arrestar a los
sospechosos
le dio golpe la policía registrado el
caso como un acto terrorista en vídeos
compartidos en las redes sociales se
puede ver como la turba golpea a la
víctima al son de consignas contra la
blasfemia la policía local informó que
la violencia se originó después de que
se regarán rumores de que el gerente
habría roto y desechado una ficha
religioso grupo de la sociedad civil
dicen que la acusación de blasfemia
normalmente puede ser usada para
resolver venganzas personales donde las
minorías son el objetivo
y alguien puede decir que este hombre ha
cometido blasfemia por lo que creo que
es hora de que revisemos la ley de la
blasfemia es hora de que revisemos las
políticas
pakistán reportó 200 casos de blasfemia
el año pasado el número anual más alto
en la historia de este país según un
informe de 2020 ha habido al menos 78
asesinatos extrajudiciales que responden
a la blasfemia y acusaciones de
apostasía o abandono de la fe